salve buonasera buonasera
parliamo di futuro e il 2 novembre la
commissione intergovernativa sui
cambiamenti climatici presenterà darà
dopo un anno che vanno presentando i
vari pezzi il quinto rapporto sul clima
e quindi innanzitutto vi devo dire che
le notizie sono molto negative per il
futuro del pianeta e cerchiamo di vedere
un po quali sono i rischi quali sono
diciamo in che termini sta nel pianeta
il problema climatico e poi un caso di
soluzioni positive
ecco quello che mi sembra importante che
il futuro è già tra noi noi lo vediamo
già e ci sono aree del mondo in cui
questo futuro si appalesa in maniera
evidente allora il punto è questo
cambiamento del clima
quanto è pesante e che cosa sta
producendo noi abbiamo una situazione
abbastanza una forma abbastanza
drammatica nel senso che utilizzando le
fonti fossili stiamo scaricando in altro
sfera gas che modificano la composizione
chimica dell'atmosfera e consentono
all'atmosfera di accumulare molta più
energia dal sole
questo cambiamento un cambiamento
epocale tanto che
il premio nobel per la chimica crutzen
ha definito un termine per definire una
nuova era geologica l'antropocene cioè
l'era in cui la storia della natura è
influenzata dalla civiltà industriale
del luogo all'ora
intanto abbiamo un fenomeno molto
particolare cioè che gli oni i nostri
oceani stanno assorbendo gran parte
dell'aumento di temperatura e questo si
sta trasformando in una migrazione di
specie verso nord e in una
acidificazione dell'oceano perché la
neve carbonica che viene assorbita in
parte dell'oceano è una ce lo abbiamo
già la per la visione che gli impatti
negativi sono maggiori di quelli
positivi in particolare nella produzione
di cibo è come se noi stessi o rendendo
il nostro pianeta via via sempre meno
ospitale
pochi lo sanno ma ogni anno nel mondo i
rifugiati per ragioni di disastri
naturali perché sono un gran parte
legati a fenomeni climatici sono tre
volte i rifugiati che scappano da guerre
cioè già oggi il clima fa il triplo
delle guerre come dal 2002 al 2011 la
superficie della ghiacciato della
groenlandia e ha perso ghiaccio sei
volte più velocemente rispetto al
decennio precedente quindi noi vediamo
che i fenomeni vanno accelerando quello
che è importante è questo
cosa ci dicono i climatologi i
climatologi ci dicono due cose
fondamentali
una è che colpa nostra cioè il no
aprirlo al 95 per cento di probabilità è
colpa dell'uomo se l'atmosfera sta
cambiando in questo modo è la cosa più
scandalosa di tutte è che rispetto alle
riserve fossili che sono presenti nel
sottosuolo particolare carbone petrolio
e gas
noi abbiamo questo compito da fare per
evitare i danni maggiori cioè lasciare
sotto terra
i tre quarti delle riserve fossi ora voi
capite che in un pianeta che ha già
visto due guerre per il petrolio dire
che per salvare il clima bisogna
lasciare la maggior parte delle riserve
fosse sotto terra è una cosa uno
scandalo ed è uno scandalo anche se nei
nostri paesi occidentali ormai gli studi
che dimostrano la fattibilità tecnica ed
economica di scenari energetici basati
sulle rinnovabili
la critica che ci viene fatta ci si ma
noi possiamo anche cambiare però che
succede tanto india cina questi paesi
continuano ad andare a carbone è vero
c'è una notizia positiva è che quella
che nell'ultimo anno il
la cina per la prima volta nella storia
ha diminuito il consumo di carbone però
come greenpeace
abbiamo fatto un esperimento sul campo
perché le chiacchiere come si trova
stanno a zero
siamo un'associazione di attivisti
presente in 42 paesi nel mondo abbiamo
fatto un esperimento nel nord est
dell'india nel bihar nel villaggio di
terna i 2.200 persone e abbiamo
installato assieme a una basics che
sarebbe una banca di microcredito che in
india a 2 milioni di famiglie con
clienti e quindi conosce è un soggetto
indiano che già presta soldi per varie
iniziative di microcredito
abbiamo fatto la prima microrete
interamente alimentata a solare e quindi
sono pannelli solari che caricano delle
batterie e in questo villaggio di 2.200
abitanti dove prima c'era un generatore
diesel che dava la luce per tre ore al
giorno
la banca dei poster a scuola dove i
bambini imparavano i computer in teoria
perché la maggior parte delle ore non
c'era corrente adesso da luglio hanno la
luce 24 ore al giorno e quindi siamo
riusciti a dare la luce a 2.200 persone
ea installare 10 sistemi di pompaggio
dell'acqua perché ne sta in una zona
rurale dell'india
uno può di ravenna questo è una goccia
che avete fatto per quanto diciamo così
possiamo dire bravi da una goccia
nell'oceano si è una goccia nell'oceano
ma che ha una caratteristica particolare
nel bihar 103 milioni di abitanti
nordest dell'india una ragione più
povere dell'india la 83 per cento delle
persone non ha accesso alla luce
villaggi come tarnai ce ne sono 19 mila
solo nel piano
e sono più di 50 mila in tutta l'india
quindi questo sistema che un sistema
diciamo così non è semplicemente un dono
che abbiamo fatto ma è un progetto che
verrà ripagato dai cittadini perché
basics aperto un servizio che offre ora
in tutta l'india per poter replicare
questa esperienza e quindi stanno oggi e
sperimentando il sistema per pagare la
bolletta della luce attraverso gli
smartphone attraverso computer e l'hanno
appena finito c'è un sito che si chiama
tarnai league dove vengono aggiornate
tutte le informazioni in cui hanno
concordato con il villaggio la tariffa
che possono permettersi di pagare questo
è un micro esempio ma il punto è che noi
il segnale che non vogliamo dare è che
il cambiamento è possibile e che certe
volte il cambiamento più rapido di
quello che noi stessi speriamo e già
successo
noi facciamo continuamente analisi e
rapporti sulle fonti rinnovabili e sulle
diverse questioni ambientali e vediamo
come per esempio nelle fonti rinnovabili
in alcuni anni il mercato è andato più
rapidamente di quello che noi stessi
speravamo
quindi per quanto lo stato di
distruzione del pianeta purtroppo non ci
lascia molto ottimisti un'associazione
di attivisti di un'associazione che vede
sempre il bicchiere mezzo vuoto
per esempio il m pieno il bicchiere
mezzo vuoto lo chiamò al governo ma su
quello mezzo pieno dobbiamo lavorare
perché i cambiamenti possono iniziare e
anche se sembra impossibile perché certe
volte sembra impossibile riuscire a
vincere io sono convinto che la storia
ci dice che effettivamente anche
partendo da piccoli numeri in fondo
greenpeace in tutto siamo 45.000
attivisti in tutto il mondo 3 milioni
sostenitori il pianete ha fatto di
miliardi irab i tanti ma abbiamo visto
che è possibile anche partendo da
piccoli numeri generare grandi
cambiamenti
con questo con questo messaggio che vi
vorrei lanciare uno dei nostri video che
proprio è una specie di come posso dire
richiamo a tutti alla all'azione grazie